click like this okay so let's say that
you're a cruel professor as we all are
of course you know really are good at
heart but you got a you got a treat your
students a little rough and let's say
you know homework is coming up which
means for you you have a deadline you
got to put some hard problems in the
homework as soon as possible so you know
fine you're just like off with some
random she has about three side problems
on there and I'll surely keep them busy
okay so what is a three sign instance
just to remind you I'm always gonna use
I for an instance I really wish I could
click here okay I don't know what's
happened but now we're in good shape
okay so 3sat instance looks like this
there's n variables x1 through xn
they're supposed to be assigned values 1
0 and 1 and I'm always gonna write Delta
n for the number of constraints okay so
Delta is like the density of constraints
and each constraint is in three side and
or of three literals that literal is a
variable or its negation okay so it's
gonna have Delta n constraints and what
I said random 3sat I wasn't being like
casual I'm really going to talk about
random three sides so this is the case
were literally all the constraints are
chosen uniformly at random which
variables to apply the or to and whether
or not to indicate them is it's all
chosen at random
so that's 3sat instance i okay now you
ask yourself what delta should you
choose to really give your students a
tough time because if you said Delta
very small they're very few constraints
they'll be probably any fool could find
a satisfying assignment to that and
conversely if you said Delta really high
there's like tons and tons of
constraints like any fool can easily
recognize that this thing won't be
satisfiable you have to be careful so
let's put an axis here for Delta and it
turns out there's some like special
metric number for three side for point
two six six seven or the first few
digits such that when Delta is less than
this threshold when you choose I at
random in this way it'll be satisfied
with very high probability and when
Delta is above this threshold it'll be
unsatisfiable with very high probability
okay this actually I guess technically
it's not prison but it's proven for
sufficiently value large values of three
but I didn't think sly and son anyway
it's true we won't be very concerned
actually about this precise number just
that in some range is satisfiable and in
some range is unsatisfiable okay so now
if you're gonna choose Delta to be I
don't know four or something and put
that on your homework like you know tell
me about this three side and since then
you know with you should write the
homework to say prove that the following
instance is satisfiable okay we're
actually not gonna talk about this
regime in this talk because you know
it's too easy like for example what is
the proof that the students come up
what's gonna look like it'll just be
like set X 1 to be 0 so X 2 W 1 set X 3
to be 0 etc it's very easy for them to
copy off each other also it's very easy
for the TAS to grade it you know they
just got tick tick tick tick tick and
that's a cruel professor we want to be
cruel both to the students and the TAS
so instead we're going to talk and let's
talk about the the unsatisfiable regime
so you're gonna imagine that maybe you
said Delta to be 10 you pick a random 3
side instance and then you put on their
homework like prove that the following
specific instance is unsatisfiable okay
there's a bit of a subtle point here
which I want to just emphasize as I said
I'm not gonna be super concerned about
this exact threshold so let's imagine
Delta's a bit bigger than that like 10
or something in that case the proof of
the mathematical theorem that when you
do this random 3sat instance with Delta
at least 10 that with very high
probability it'll be unsatisfiable it's
super duper easy anybody can just write
it down in two lines use the Chernoff
bound and it's fine
but the thing I see once you actually
quench that instance like once actually
draw it and like put it down the piece
of paper like prove that this particular
instance is unsatisfiable that could
actually be hard okay so the students
may well know that you drew this
instance uniformly at random with Delta
equals 10 but like once they're actually
face to face with the input sentence and
make heart be hard to actually prove
it's unsatisfiable okay the student
could like write down a whole truth
table for all the possible assignments
to X and check that none of them work
but you know they'll take 2 to the N
time and the student doesn't have time
for that now if you're really cool you
know three side has been worked on a lot
so you might try to go to more general
csps so they don't get any clues and
what is the general CSP it's that sense
for constraint satisfaction problem what
does it look like sort of similar so in
a general CSP U of n variables x1
through xn and they're supposed to be a
value assigned values and some small
domains so in three side it with 0 and
one or maybe it could be like 0 1 and 2
or something and I'm still gonna have
delta x end constraints but each
constraint is some predicate applied to
a small number of variables ok and they
don't have to have the same arity but
they may as well without loss of
generality here all the predicates have
very dirty v ok and the constraint
satisfaction problem itself is sort of
defined by
it's constraints or what predicates you
allow so again you have some small set
of allowable predicates and each
constraint on your piece of paper P I
should be from that small set okay so
for 3sat you can either think that like
you have one constraint which is like
the or of three variables but you can
also apply it to literals or you can
think of that as being there like eight
different constraints or with every
possible way of negating some of the
input variables okay well actually
probably tend to think about the first
one in this talk okay and again once you
fix this like let's say class of allowed
constraint types a random instances just
you choose like everything totally
randomly like which which variables to
apply it to which order which which P I
is comes from the set script B
everything has chosen at random okay so
this very good general class of
algorithmic tasks of course the problem
again is to decide if there are settings
for the variables and assignment to the
variables that make all the constraint
predicates true it's a very general
class and includes lots of well-known
things so here's one other example
besides three set so let's say your
domain for your variables is red green
and blue and your set of predicates is
just the single binary dis equality
predicate so like the homework problem
looks like this and I guess you can
recognize that this is nothing more than
the following situation this represents
a graph and you're interested in whether
or not it's 3 colorable okay and in the
random model like all these pairs are
chosen uniformly at random so it's just
like it's like a GNP or G and M I guess
random graph and you're interested in
its 3 colorability or again n was fixed
to a delta x n ok so that's one example
now once you get this graph right again
to illustrate this point like you know
you know if delta is large enough bigger
than 10 it's gonna be not 3 colorable
with very high probability but when
you're faced with the actual graph you
know you have to figure out how you
could actually certify that so you might
like hope that maybe there's like a copy
of k4 in there and then you'd be like
this one is definitely not 3 colorable
but you know that's not gonna happen
unless Delta is like let's say at least
n to the one third because k4 s don't
show up in a random graph until the
number of edges is like n to the 4/3
okay here's another quick example back
to the boolean domain and I'm going to
Majan that p is this weirdo predicate
called TSA which has err t5 and you can
apply it to literals you don't feel like
studying this example too carefully this
weirdo predicate tsa is like you XOR
together the first three bits and then
XOR it with the end of the last two bits
the exact details are not important but
I bring it up because this particular
predicate and random CSP is based on
this predicate are quite relevant for
cryptography so in 2000 Ortega Reich had
this proposal for like new ways to
construct cryptographic objects like
pseudo-random generators and one-way
functions that would be very efficient
and they're based on the potential
hardness of solving random CSPs
and you don't really care what the
predicate you use is as long as it turns
it gives you hard problems see what
these problems to be hard to solve and
you also for this application want Delta
to be large because Delta kind of
corresponds to the stretch of the
pseudo-random generator that you're
potentially constructing okay so all at
least is its following motivation for
what problem I want to talk about here
which is this let's say you fix some
predicate that's gonna be your
constraints how large can this cruel
first professor set Delta to be when
he's creating random CSP instances with
this predicate such that the students
are going to have a hard time in other
words such that the task of proving that
a randomly chosen instance is
unsatisfiable well with high probability
be impossible for any polynomial time
student or algorithm I guess
okay so the most familiar CSP is
three-set so let me tell you what's
known for this one so we're in this
regime where Delta's big enough that the
three side instances are going to be
unsatisfiable once you choose them at
random
now once Delta is at least n squared we
where the number of constraints is like
Delta n so let's end cube constraints
that's pretty much all the possible
constraints there only n cubed basically
choices of three variables so that's
going to be like trivially unsatisfiable
and trivial to come up with a proof is
like if you gave someone the complete
graph and said prove that this is not 3
colorable that's easy the first
interesting result in this area by beam
carpet a C and sax 498 it showed an
efficient algorithm that could come up
with proofs of unsatisfiability with
high probability when Delta was at least
about n ok when they're about N squared
constraints
ok those a combinatorial algorithm and
it got really interesting I think a few
years later with a paper of Friedman and
dirt from 2001 where they found an
efficient algorithm that can refute or
you know prove unsatisfiability
of most 3sat instances the suitors the
constraint densities at least end to the
0.5 so the number of constraints is
about and to the three-halves
I should mention here and throughout the
rest of the talk there's like poly log
factors on all these expressions which
I'm not going to mention ok so this
algorithm works in a somewhat surprising
way you know studies of random matrices
and eigenvalues and so forth
based on the instance and that's all we
know so like 16 years later we don't
know any efficient algorithms for
refuting random instances in this this
range of deltas
okay now that's the cruel professor you
might wonder what the students are gonna
you know what strategy they're gonna use
so this algorithm for 3sat it's what's
specific to 3sat but actually we now
know there's one generic algorithm that
will also do the same job and it's this
SOS algorithm or sum of squares
algorithm but made appearance in the
title of the talk so let me tell you the
story with it
so this SOS algorithm it's the a you
like the polynomial time algorithm that
all the kids these days are like using
to solve their problems okay so this is
a polynomial time algorithm and it's
super generic you can use it to try to
refute any instance of any csb you just
get an instance of a CSB you say I'm
gonna try to run the SOS algorithm on it
to see if it's to try and certify that
it's it's unsatisfiable in fact you can
use the SOS to try to certify the pretty
much any mathematical statement is it's
a not true if you want to refute any
such statement but will stick to it in
the context of of csps
and you know the good thing about it is
that this SOS algorithm it kind of
encapsulates like all known techniques
like based on linear programming semi
definite programming hierarchies you
know there's a little asterisk there
because some experts may quibble a
little with what I'm saying but
basically any algorithm that runs in
polynomial time we know we also kind of
know that this SOS algorithm works
equally well so like if you gave me
today if I was solving the homework and
you gave me some instance to try to
refute to show one set of five all I
would try that so I saw algorithm and
then if it didn't work I'd say well I
got nothing so I'm building up this
algorithm a little bit because the
result is about proving that this
algorithm will fail in certain
circumstances
okay so this is not the fear I'm gonna
talk about today but it's something I
proved a couple years ago with Sarah
Allen and David Whitmer and it's about
how well the SS algorithm works for
random instances of constraint
satisfaction problems and it says the
following let's say you have some
general constraint satisfaction problem
P look let's focus on the specific case
where the variables are boolean zero and
one and you've like one predicate P
that's applied randomly two literals
variables and their negations so tells
you a range of Delta is where the SOS
algorithm will work okay so this s why
this algorithm will work in polynomial
time to you know prove that these
instances are unsatisfied we'll provide
a delta is big enough and how big does
Delta have to be it's a certain power of
n that depends on the predicate P so has
this parameter or complexity of P which
is some easy to calculate integer I'm
gonna tell you the definition but you'll
eventually get it later which somehow I
measure is something about pseudo
randomness related to P let me just say
that in the case of K sets the
complexity of this predicate is K okay
when P is the or or some function of air
DK so particular if it's 3sat this
number up here is three so this is n to
the 3 minus 2 over 2 that's end of the
half like it was in the earlier
algorithm ok so this again is a
different way to certify that random
3sat instances are unsatisfiable once
delft is bigger than about and to the
one-half so SMS will work so you know
you know ideally like to have it work
when Delta is bigger than a constant but
I wasn't the best we can do so we go
back to the professor's perspective and
try to make things a little harder so
let's imagine that the homework further
says like for full credit I don't want
you to just prove that this instance I
is unsatisfiable I want you to actually
prove a stronger statement saying that
like every assignment to the variables X
doesn't even satisfy a beta fraction of
the constraints ok you should try to do
that for beta as small as you can so
it's not just unsatisfiable it's like
quite unsatisfiable so if beta is 1 this
yellow command is the same as asking you
to prove that the instance is just unset
viable but you know you might try to
prove that no assignment satisfies even
90% of the constraints would be a
stronger statement so we would like to
do that and let me tell you about this
problem in the context of three side so
we have this Delta axis and now we're
gonna add a beta axis so here's the
truth this is not hard to prove so if
you pick a random 3sat instance with
some density Delta then as soon as
Delta's bigger than some constants I
don't know ten or something you can
easily prove that not only is it
unsatisfiable but every assignment to
the variables satisfies at most seven
eighths of the constraints well seven
eighths plus some little low of one okay
I'm also going to ignore plus or minus
little of ones in this talk so becomes
very unsatisfiable and in case you don't
know why 7/8 it's because actually any
3sat instance at all always has an
assignment that satisfies at least 7/8
of the constraints let's by the
probabilistic method if you pick a
random assignment it'll satisfy 7/8 of
the constraints and expectation because
the or predicate is true with
probability 7/8 on a random input so the
algorithm it's not just good at refuting
things it can actually try to you know
prove stronger statements of this form
and what we actually showed a couple
years ago is this which is even better
than when I told you before so for three
side as long as Delta the density is
below and to the point five like SOS
can't really do anything it can't even
in certify unsatisfiability but once you
get bigger than this end to the point
five and so it's not only shows with
high probability that the random
instance is unsatisfiable it shows that
any assignment satisfies at most seven
eighths plus some other little of one
fraction of constraints so it really
actually certifies the truth about how
satisfiable these instances are
okay so a paper we also worked on just
arbitrary CSPs giving a predicate P so
in the picture for any any CSP in the
same situation where it's very easy to
prove that as soon as the the clause the
constraint density gets bigger than a
constant the best assignment will only
satisfy some constant fraction of the
constraints and that constant fraction
is like the the expected value of the
predicate P the same probabilistic
method argument and what we proved about
that so s algorithm in this case it's
kind of a crazy it has a picture that
looks like this so let me try to
interpret this for you so we showed that
this Sol Sol algorithm kind of does a
better and better job of satisfying like
very unsatisfiability as the number of
constraints goes up okay so we showed
that what's the constraint density is a
bit bigger than a constant SOS will
certify that a random instance satisfies
no more than Sigma to a pea fraction of
constraints but again is some like easy
to compute the real number depending on
P and I'll actually define what it is in
a second and then it's the number of
constraints gets bigger and bigger
SOS doesn't do anything but as soon as
it goes past this threshold on to the
point five SOS can suddenly now certify
that random instances have the property
that any assignment satisfies at most a
sigma three fraction of constraints and
then once you cross a density n SOS will
satisfy that penny into any assignment
satisfies at most a sigma for a fraction
of constraints and so forth and so on up
to once you go up to end to the era T of
P minus two over two SOS will certify
the truth that like every assignment
satisfies at most
basically this fraction of constraints
the Sigma's need not be all different
they aren't in the case of 3sat we'll
see that in three sides case this equals
one and they are like actually
decreasing like this but they also don't
decrease like at regular interval or
anything they can basically be any
collection of numbers between one in
this
they're just cleaning up a picture here
actually one year later some people
local here Raghav and Rowan shrum showed
a stronger statement you know if you
know about SMS you know there's like a
parameter to it actually and you can
make it a version of it that rot doesn't
run in polynomial time it runs in some
larger amount of time but has the
potential to be more powerful so that's
this like kind of power versus running
time trade-off and they show that if you
do the version of SOS that takes two to
the end to the epsilon time for any
epsilon then it gets better and what
effect does it have it basically is the
effect of squeezing a horizontal axis so
like the stair step you can still
achieve but all these ends change to end
to the one minus Epsilon
so this is everything that we could
prove about this powerful SOS algorithm
in the context of random CSPs and the
result I'm telling you about today is
that everything on this slide is tight
it's completely tied up to like a log
factors and lower order terms in other
words
SOS does not do any better than this
okay there you can show that this is the
exact through behavior of how well SOS
does and that's kind of surprising
because you know the behavior we prove
is kind of this weird you know stair
step and it shows that this exact
three-way trade-off between the
constraint density and the quality of
the refutation and the running time of
SOS this whole three-way tear it off is
is tight
okay so that's a negative result about
this particular SOS algorithm and you
know if you're an optimistic person like
me or you're optimistic about pessimism
about hardness then you know you might
think that maybe this is evidence that
like actually no polynomial time
algorithm or no algorithm running in
more time than your allotting to SOS can
do better than this for refuting random
three CSP instances and then then maybe
therefore this is evidence that the
Associated cryptographic objects you
know suggested by gold right etc could
be secure with these parameter settings
I do want to say some slightly technical
things so let me tell you what this
Sigma T of P is okay so it's this so P
is some predicate of era DK let's say
operating on you know K bits and what is
the value you look at all T wise uniform
distributions on 0 1 to the K so these
are distributions that for every subset
of T of the K positions size marginal is
the uniform distribution and then you
just see how much probability mass X I
puts on satisfying assignments for P ok
so you try to find the the best T wise
uniform distribution in terms of having
a lot of probability mass on P
satisfying assignments let me do an
example in 3 set P is the or predicate
on three inputs so there are the seven
satisfying assignments for an or so
let's compute Sigma 2 of P here you have
to look for a pairwise uniform
distribution that has a lot of it's
probability mass on these strings and in
fact you can get a hundred percent of
the probability mass on these strings
you just like sy be this well-known
pairwise uniform distribution that's
probably a quarter on these four strings
the four strings that add up to 1 mod -
that's a pairwise uniform distribution
it has all of its probability mass on
the support of the or predicate so Sigma
2 P is 1 then Sigma 3 of P is 7/8
because well if you look at 3 was
uniform distribution
that just means the uniform distribution
thus no other such distribution and the
uniform distribution puts exactly 7/8 of
its probability mass on these 7 strings
the computer its Sigma 2 and Sigma 3 so
if you go back to this picture let me
interpret it for you a little bit
this means that Sigma 2 in the case of
three side is 1 this gets out what Luca
was saying and indeed for SOS like it
doesn't do a good job of anything until
Delta is like n to the point 5 and then
once Delta gets passed then to the point
5 Sigma 3 of sat 3 side is 7/8 which is
actually the same as the expectation so
that's the point at which SOS has
performance jumps down to being optimal
so this was the picture of how 3sat
works with SOS and like you can infer it
from the calculations on the previous
slide
okay water how much time do I have
oh great so these slides are for you
moderate because you know you're the top
expert in this this room on this topic
so here you go okay so if you know a
little bit about SOS you know in order
to show that degree dsos algorithm fails
on some instances fails too let's just
talk about refuting okay fails to refute
satisfiability you need to show that the
instance is somehow like degree D pseudo
satisfiable I'm glad I could work with
pseudo adjectives into this talk just as
a softer the title of the conference so
what does that mean
it means that there's a degree D pseudo
distribution on global assignments or
you can also think of it as a signed
probability a measure on global
assignments and it's the measure is that
denoted eat Whittle such that being a
pseudo distribution a degree D to deter
distribution means you kind of look like
an actual probability distribution like
a positive probability distribution so
you need three properties that the the
pseudo expectation of 1 is 1 and this
property encapsulate that like this
pseudo distribution kind of looks like
it's assigning all the excise 0 or 1 in
the sense that like X I squared is the
same as X I under this pseudo
distribution and this is the main thing
you need and it's where the degree D
thing comes in this the pseudo
distribution or signed measure should
have the property that at least it looks
positive if you plug in the square of a
polynomial okay so if this was a real
positive distribution of course this
would always be non-negative and these
pseudo distributions have the property
that at least they're not negative if
these degrees at most D over 2 okay so
that's a degree D pseudo distribution
and you need to show that there is one
of these objects that also looks like
it's satisfying the in fact that looks
like it's a distribution on satisfying
assignments for your 3sat instance you
know there are no satisfying assignments
for the 3sat instance so in the case of
like let's say 3sat you would want if
this was one of the constraints either X
1 or not X 3 or X 9 you would want that
your pseudo distribution had this
polynomial with expectation 0 okay so
that
in particular it means that under this
distribution either x1 is 2 or x3 is
false or x9 is true so that's your task
to construct this object and even better
if you get into these things we actually
not only find a pseudo distribution that
makes all these things satisfied we even
cook it up so that the the the pseudo
distributions induced local distribution
on any let's say three variables in a
constraint looks like this side that
goes into the definition of like you
know this Sigma T so this is like that
you know T Y is uniform distribution
supported on the predicate we even want
eat Whittle to like locally look like
that distribution so it's not only
satisfying it but satisfying it
according to this local distribution ok
and so if you're an expert like you're
the Tyr whoever they've done stuff like
this in the past and here's the plan
always you define a notion of closure
and a constraint hypergraph and then you
prove that the closures are small in
random hypergraphs and then you define
this pseudo distributions moments on
small sets of variables as based on a
planted distribution coming from this
slide and then finally like the pain and
suffering is showing and it satisfies
this positive semi definiteness
condition that it has a it gives a non
negative expectation to all squared
polynomials of low degree so we did all
this and it was the case that still like
all the main pain and suffering was down
here but actually one thing that I think
it was nice is in all the previous
papers there was like slightly different
definitions of closure I should I think
this closure dates back maybe it's a
some work of Sascha's and I kind of
think we found like the right definition
of closure it facilitated us being able
to prove this part and it seemed kind of
nice so that's that here's my last slide
so in summary I think there's something
interesting going on in random
constraint satisfaction problems with
not just satisfiability thresholds but
like algorithmic thresholds as well so
you know if you take your
you can random CSP instances we tend to
know that there's some satisfiability
threshold where if Delta is smaller than
its satisfiable with high probability
and if it's bigger it's unsatisfiable
with very high probability and there's
been working like especially the
statistical physics community about
understanding whether or not and there
actually is a lower threshold for
efficient certification so it seems that
there's a lower threshold where in Delta
down here they're efficient algorithms
for certifying satisfiability like
finding satisfying assignments and here
it's satisfiable but it's maybe
algorithmically hard to find satisfying
assignments we kind of saw in this talk
and I think it's a bit interesting is
that there may be is sort of a similar
threshold above the satisfiability
threshold where if Delta is much bigger
than this threshold you can efficiently
certify that the instances are
unsatisfiable and maybe below this
threshold or unsatisfiable but it's like
very hard to prove that and maybe if
you're you know really speculative you
might think that this threshold is sort
of the SOS satisfiable pseudo
satisfiability threshold and as for open
problems one one that I like is to maybe
I ignore kind of constant factors
everywhere here and it'd be interesting
to kind of drill down into them and then
you could start talking about this whole
picture maybe of algorithmic thresholds
for things like K colorability and
random graphs which i think is very nice
and natural problem okay thank you
[Applause]
it is one there are some easy predicates
which are been visible no cost
elimination of them should be something
qualitative difference between better
equal one bit has more than one for
Jennifer tickets
it's definitely qualitatively different
so I mean when I said like SOS kind of
gives us all the known techniques it's
kind of if you are having epsilon Xin
this beta so like if you want to not
just refute but like refute that there's
an assignment satisfying a 1 minus
epsilon fraction of constraints then I
think maybe SOS is the most general
thing but definitely there is something
different about beta equals 1 you know
Gaussian elimination and well of course
the whole dichotomy conjecture is a
totally different realm of realm of
things so I'm not sure SOS is relevant
for that results actually you know gave
a trade off for every value of the
degree so I kind of implicitly equated
it with the running time so the running
time for a degree D is like n to the D
so when I was talking about you know
raga Ventura and shrubs results for
running time 2 to the n to the epsilon
that really meant degree n to the
epsilon and epsilon was a free parameter
there our lower bound applies for every
degree even a function of n so we have
the tight complete trade-off in terms of
the SOS degree you know the quality of
the SOS reputation and the constraint
density
any more questions thank you
[Applause]